the goas bear shooting one that's
blocked gas bear with it again
to Raymond top of the right Circle
pulls it back nice play across scores
[Music] [Applause]
pan on the red wi power play went South and he
wasn't on it they made some changes he's been
on it he's been a net front presence a lot here
he was in the shooting position and boy did he
release that quickly Lucas Raymond with a really
good move at the high slot against two Minnesota
flares and then a quick pass and if this shot
doesn't get off the Stick of Pon the minute it
gets there Pon wield one back this way for sherat
back in for cop behind for fabric Baron heads off
on a change as the Red Wings still have it and
that shot floated [Applause] in round it comes
for to Brink it for JT comp at a goal and an
assist at Boston spin back by Duane shot got St
goodro in behind cadro back to the point pinballs
around oh lion made the save did here today dances
Home State team Puck bouncing down right in front
they Jam away comes close to gos topar pass it off
Freeman gos topar doesn't shoot it gives it to
Pon gos Spar firing that one gets knocked down
big crowd in front and a save by gust they'll box
as you can see they'll give you the outside they
do not pressure they won't come forward that
shot block rebound Lin Raymond Pon fire save
made rebound cleared on the wing for [Applause]
bagoan skipped off cop loose Puck here saved by
lion top to retrieve Raymond cuts to the middle
knocked off his stick kept the live by Hall for
o ma tipped in front of the goal by Pon usually
means 76% right but there's a 24% chance so so
you can still get in there's a shot from Ras
M get stopped by gustas Minnesota quick change
quick up here for pon pon cuts to the net good
takeaway though by Brock Faber Pon stays with
it in back of the goal for comper angled back
here to Raymond to gosis Bear Dylan Lin Pon
Waits rink wide Raymond back to gosis Bear again
to Raymond to gosis Bear the shot and a glove save
they're get get the Lux that guy logs a a lot
of ice time 24 plus minutes a night for Jonas
Brin here's Spurgeon back for Baldi that
goes High 15 to go in the period played
back high slot they [Applause] score and
who else Capri off now lion got a piece
of it and you're going into the the dressing
room now even it went off more more Exciter
what happened and found its way to the back
of the net barck neck maybe after that yeah
double double carum so they Minnesota Wild get
a break one they've been looking for for a long
time and Joel Ericson [Applause]
e shot in the lineon got a piece of it's at least
8 in shorter than Justin Hall at least MH and he
took a shot with that stick right there that gets
stopped by Gus Johansson again Eric backed his
way knocked away to Brink it with a lead pass for
spraw spraw firing out post wow it squeak through
the furly gates and hit the Post 25 minutes of
hockey and here was strong a moment ago he's
got a good strong shot and this one just trickled
off the base of the goal po Hall protects the puck
checked by derer Hall again deer's got it one
more time laid it back save made short side on
duim duim knocked down by Hall then der put it in
back of the net mat was out position but able to
get a stick on the puck kept alive here by gdol
in deep it goes good save by lion off Spurgeon
maroon over with it had won
three consecutive cups with St
[Music] Louis's came right in front a good save by
lion capriso out with Marco Rossi and zuk
Carell Rossy leaves it for zuk Carell Rossy
who missed a full year due to Long Haul Co
just wasn't right but he's coming on now the
youngster number 23 in white zcell gives it
to broin there he is all alone but he sent
that one wide did Rossy two big bodies there
Eric neck back of the net protects the puck
gives it to Johansson Spurgeon to Middleton
that shot high you're not Tom barasso Hall
of Famer coming out of high school pretty
much anymore back in for bagoan the veteran
Defender short side held out by lion back
for JT Comer down low for Alex to Brink
it Comer again took the shot save made by
Philip [Applause] gustus here's sprong in
for Petri back out front and a chance for
spraw the brink it maroon over there to get it
back to the line here for Faber orer markman's
long pass a good one for Pino the Goan save made
by lion maroon on the rebound there's a shot again
Hartman point shot Spurgeon saved by lion
rebound save by lion on rosi Minnesota out
shooting Detroit in the middle stanza 11 to three
so plenty of room here four on four Puck turned
over inside the line then grabbed back here
by Rodin right to the net and a save by lion
came free for gosp for Dylan Lin up with Raymond
Lin firing rebound Lin scars oh oh my [Applause]
goodness [Music] and he has to draw somebody
with him but a juicy rebound for Dylan L
even though the golender got a piece of it he
finishes it off to put Detroit in front holy
smoke everybody Lefty comes in he
moves gosis Bear right behind him
and Pon a little wider and sure enough
right to gos bear for pan he scores
[Music]
Dylan Lin got it checked by capriso out to Ras
M empty net for conord Aus
bear with the empty net he
scores Shane Gus despair makes it 4 to one he's
got a goal and three [Music] assists okay his
second career four-point game Trevor Thompson
gets a Christmas gift and so do you so do I oh
my god [Music] wow be out shot poorly in the
second and in the third this is an interesting
win for Detroit but one that's going to set
very deeply into the the core of this team